salesperson should walk away from a sale
rather than sell something that would be
a bad fit and I have done that
so A salesperson must
transmit to the prospector buyer
the notion that they are there to help
them and they're they're trying to what
I used to say to people is you know my
job was to get you promoted if you get
if you buy what I'm selling you and you
get promoted then that's what I want
you know we both went on that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I am with Steve Weinberg who has
spent his life selling and helping
others sell better more and faster he
recently led the Acuity sales team to
new sales accomplishments for 12 years
Acuity is a British Dutch technology
company that is now part of Lexus Nexus
risk systems and is a relx subsidiary it
provides anti-money laundering and
electronic Payment Solutions to
financial institutions and corporations
while at Acuity as a salesperson and
simultaneously as a manager of a team of
salespeople Steve closed the largest
sale in the company history he has over
three decades of leadership experience
and sales including Vice presidencies at
duned Bradstreet software AC Nielsen
soulcorp and is a senior manager at
Deloitte and tush he is an expert at
building guiding and sustaining High
Caliber sales and creating exemplary
standards and account management Steve
led many sales kickoffs and introduced
formal sales training at several
companies
I'm excited to have you here and listen
to your journey and put a little bit of
a spotlight on on your path and as a
sales leader growing sales organizations
and and unlocking a little bit about the
mystery of what it means to sell
sell great product and so Steve again
thank you for being here with me
I'd love to learn with you you know what
you know what got you into sales in the
first place how did you discover that
sales were your thing
well I had somewhat of unique past to
sales I I started out in accounting and
I'm a CPA
and I loved Accounting in finance and I
was doing very well in it and enjoying
it and the company that I was with
decided to implement some software
packages and they assigned me the task
of of making sure that everything went
well in in getting it up and running and
so I did the first one which was a fixed
asset accounting uh system and then
after that they have to be doing
accounts payable one that the general
lecture one and then a payroll one
and then uh and everything was going
well for me and the company and in
accounting and then I went to a user
meeting for the fixed asset system
company and I was offered a job by that
company named McCormick Dodge I ended up
moving back to Chicago which is where I
was from and I got into sales
uh very differently than most because I
had never really aspired to be in sales
but I knew that the product that I was
selling was much better than the
competition so I assumed at that time
that this would be really easy to sell
and I found out a little bit later there
wasn't so easy
but I enjoyed
entering in sales and I was very
successful in it
and and and and what you know what what
once you were in what really kept you
going and growing as a sales leader what
was it about the you know was it about
the the actual action the thought
process the strategy the execution
well I think it initially was the idea
of bringing solutions to people bringing
solutions that I knew that would help
them out and so I was I would I have
always been very consultative as a
Salesman
my I felt my job was to help them
fix the problems they had I call that
solutioning uh meet with them
and and since I was an accountant and
initially I was calling on accountants I
understood exactly what we were talking
about there was no language or
terminology issue and I could meet with
them and in a very non-salesy way
and explain to them how what I had could
help them out
and what appealed to me about sales
coming from accounting really was the
variety of meeting different people all
the time the challenge of making the
sale of a very competitive person I
think part of that is because I'm a very
Sports oriented person
and of course it's if you're successful
in sales it's very financially rewarding
and I earned a whole lot more in sales
than I did in accounting
yeah I love that I love the you know
learning about all about the learning
experiences so so let's dive into a
little bit about you know being a good
sales leader right and I want to focus
the first part about sales and then
transition to the leader portion so you
know over over your years as a Salesman
what what made what makes for an
effective salesman
well that's not an easy question to
answer but in uh
in my book I listed 30 traits that I
thought could be used to identify High
performers I found that when I hired
sales people that my success rate wasn't
as good as I wanted it to be initially
it was very high because I tried to
replicate myself and hire people like
myself and like that doesn't scale up so
after four or five of these I couldn't
keep doing it so I tried to hire people
with good track records and that didn't
always work either
and I kept making mistakes I thought I
thought well
what am I doing wrong here and and I
tried to identify
how do you find that best top performers
what I did find out was that they are
are very different from one to another
so if you took five top performers and
put them right next to each other it
would be hard to find common traits
between them
no matter I mean some of them are team
players some are not team players some
are extrovert some are introvert some
are male some are female some are high
high energy people uh but there are some
traits that that were common to all of
them for example High egos so in
normally
a high performing salesperson had a high
Eco and sometimes that ego could get out
of control but that was one of the
traits I think also empathy how do you
explain that right away why what's the
what's the rationale behind that well
these people want to achieve and they
want to be recognized for their
achievement they want to be known as the
best person in the company the best
salesperson in the company they want to
be the one at the sales meeting that
gets recognized for being the top person
or one of the top people they want to go
on the achievement trip or what we used
to call the president's trip and it's it
was all about feeding their ego and
looking good in front of their spouse
and their family
it wasn't necessarily money people think
that sales people are are coin operated
or Money Motivated and certainly money
is part of the equation but I would rate
money is is about the eighth most
important to high performing salesperson
if there are many other factors that are
much more important to them uh also what
I found was that the high performers had
empathy for their customers they really
wanted to help them
the ones that did want to help them
usually didn't do all that well they
weren't able to build trust with their
customers and Prospects if you can't
build trust
you're not going to make it so there
were a number of factors in there you
know for when we're looking at
specifically at trust let's talk a
little bit about that what have you
learned to be effective modes of
communication or different things that
one could do to generate
um you know healthy trust between you
and their client well first of all never
lie to the client and always have the in
and always have what I would call
Superior business ethics and have their
interests in my to the point where a
salesperson should walk away from a sale
rather than sell something that would be
a bad fit and I have done that
so A salesperson must
transmit to the prospect or buyer
the notion that they are there to help
them and they're they're trying to what
I used to say to people is you know my
job was to get you promoted if you get
if you buy what I'm selling you and you
get promoted then that's what I want
you know we both win on that
so I wanted them to have success
personally in in business-wise and of
course if that happened then it would be
also a success for me as well
but the idea of building trust takes
time it doesn't happen immediately when
you start calling on someone it takes
time and it and it can be destroyed very
quickly so it it could take months to
build it could take seconds to lose
so and sales people need to understand
that because if they ever misrepresent
or lie or exaggerate then all the trust
that they've built over the months that
they've worked with the prospect will go
away in the in the prospect will
normally buy from somebody else
yeah let's continue about your your own
Journey so you you as a Salesman and
then in sales and then I want to
transition a little bit to to the
leadership style side of your career so
yeah go ahead
well it was as I became successful in
sales and as the company grew I was
promoted initially to be a regional
sales manager uh eventually to be a vice
president of sales of the company and
then the company was later acquired by
dun and Bradstreet and I moved on to
other companies as a vice president of
sales and in in one case as the
president of the company
and while I was doing that I developed
what I called steveisms now these
steve-isms were but I would I would hand
people a bullet a sheet of paper with a
bullet with bullets on them typically
from 15 to 18 bullets and I would
explain to the sales people
what each of the items meant and how I
wanted them to operate
and sometimes they were not obvious so
for example one of my steveisms was if
you're not winning you're losing
and they would always look at me go what
doesn't that is that obvious because you
know it's either one or the other and I
would say no it's not obvious because
when I meet with you and I ask you
questions
and and I find out that you really don't
understand what's going on on the
account
then it's likely you're losing and you
don't know it so that's one of the
Stevens so
there are others as well that I used uh
and and through that I you know I was
able to
have a have a lot of success with
bringing sales people through the ranks
and had many people that became VPS of
sales at the company I was with and in
other companies as a result of of uh my
coaching and nurturing in them
my style of selling and Sales Management
was very unorthodox compared to what
many people were used to in other
companies
yeah so leadership wise
what is it like you know looking at
sales as a leader
what does it like to look at sales as a
leader
yeah what does it mean to be a leader in
in this in the world of sales you know I
I found it really challenging and every
year
if I met my quota they always gave me a
much higher quote so it was always a big
challenge at the beginning of the year
and I always thought I wouldn't make the
quote and so by the time I did make it
or exceed it I felt pretty good about it
so it was both personally rewarding to
me to achieve that but I think even more
so to see people that work for me
achieve their quotas
and what bothered me was people that
didn't achieve their quotas and I had to
spend a lot of time with them and
sometimes I was able to help them out
sometimes I was it he just didn't uh
they didn't work so and we had to move
on
but I really enjoyed helping people
what Disturbed me a lot
and was one of the reasons for me
writing the book was that historically
throughout all companies about 50
percent of all sales people do not reach
their quota
and that's astounding number in in
researching the book I went to many
sources and found the debt is a reliable
number some people will say it's 48 some
will say 52 or 56 percent but it's
around half of the people so is a sales
manager if I can change that number
so that 60 or 70 or 80 or more percent
of the people that worked for me were
successful then that was very rewarding
to me
yeah and so if and then as you
were exerting that leadership on others
you know continuing from The Challenge
and the rewards
how you know from even from a training
perspective I'm really curious to hear
what what did you find most helpful as
you were training
the you know sales people that you were
working with to become better
through the different lenses of what you
saw you know in increasing performance
which sounds it's a little bit
personalized and and nuances not
necessarily A playbook that that you
would give
well as my back well being in accounting
I was very process oriented so
accounting is really a repeated process
we start at the beginning of the month
and we go through a process at the end
of the month we start all over again and
we do what we call a closing and then we
keep doing it in month after month and
at the end of the year we do a yearly
one well in sales I tried to put in a
process as well because
as a sales manager and as a salesperson
we don't want to have everything work
randomly the best thing to do is to
build a successful process that works
well within the company now what works
what process in one company may not work
in another company even if they're
selling uh similar products because a
process has to has to be oriented to the
culture of the company and the sales
people that work there
and
where I was at we brought in sales
trainers of all from many many different
companies what I found was that every
sales trainer had great ideas and what I
would call nuggets that we could use
the problem was
that most of the time when the sales
trainers left
the
the information they gave us the data
the worksheets or whatever we practiced
all the role plays all of that went out
the window and people just reverted back
to what they were very comfortable with
and the company themselves where I was
where I worked they didn't enforce most
of them didn't enforce what they trained
people on
the other part of that was that many of
the sales trainers and there are a lot
of really good ones out there but many
of them
have not updated themselves for the
current Marketplace because the market
today
is extremely different from how it was
even five years ago and more so than 10
or 15 years ago and I you know I can get
into the differences but it's it's very
very different so if a salesperson goes
in and tells the sales people I'm sorry
if a trainer tells salespeople how to do
things that worked five or ten years ago
they may not work now and that they'll
lose credibility and the sales people
won't follow the ideas that they have
so to I guess to sum it up I believe in
in deploying a repeatable process that
works and
using that with the sales people to kind
of uh understand where they are in the
in the sales pipeline
have you have common terminology that we
use and you said to monitor their
progress in on each account
yeah that's awesome and uh I think I
love them in the process
um oriented approach I'd love to finish
off with hearing a little bit more about
about your book about above a quota
performance you know the motivation to
write the book a little bit about what
you know what what do you what are the
the the main message was and uh it
sounds like a pretty interesting read
well it's it really was kind of a labor
of love for me uh when I retired about
three years ago which was right just
before the pandemic I had in mind that I
wanted to try to do something to impact
the the unsuccessful sales people to
help them become more successful and to
help the successful people become even
more so uh before I left the company I
was with they asked me to help train the
new people and I really really enjoyed
that uh because they were very coachable
and they they sought knowledge
so what what I did was I took those
steveisms and I developed each one into
a chapter
but my motivation for that though was I
had seen
unfortunately I had seen the negative
consequences of of sales people that did
not meet their quota
and at best those sales people were put
on a plan and they were given they had
to kind of what I would call walk the
plank they'd either perform or else and
they would let go and they had to find
another top which could be very
disruptive for people but I also saw
that
that some salespeople lost their
marriages they lost their family their
connection with their children some lost
their homes some some were divorced and
in one case one committed suicide
so I saw that and that really upset me a
lot and I thought well if there's
anything I can do
to impact that in a positive manner that
would be a great contribution to the the
world today to the sales world and I
really think I can do that so what I've
done with the book is I've put these
ideas in there the book is really more
of a guide It's a how-to manual and it
can be they're 25 or 26 chapters in it
and it it can be read sequentially or
you could select a chapter and decide to
read that one for example I have a
chapter on how to use linkedin.com to
develop sales leads most people
use seal use linkedin.com for career
development and for job hunting but they
don't realize that it's a terrific tool
to to develop leads in fact I close the
largest sale in the company's history by
a multiple of eight uh by using LinkedIn
to find the person and then to approach
the person build a relationship and then
start calling on that person
so the book again like I say was really
something I always wanted to do and then
once I retired in the pandemic hit I had
a lot of time on my hands and I was able
to write it and so far I've received
some very positive feedback on it
I love it and Steve I really want to
thank you
for coming in there and for sharing
especially this last bit I think it's
going to be very relevant to it to
everybody listening and uh congrats on
an amazing journey and an amazing career
and I look forward to checking out the
book myself and and going back all the
way to the beginning of all about you
know it's all about building trust it
takes uh months to build it and begins
to break it there's no Playbook you know
there are commonalities
between top performers but at the end
it's a personalized approach and and I
really appreciate the time and the
energy so thank you very very much for
being here you're welcome Michael it's
been a pleasure
thank you
[Music]